You are listening to radiolab radiolab. W.
N y. S. C. E. N. N. P. R. Good.
Okay.
Three, two, one. Hello.
This show we are about to do, it began. Hey guys,
how's it going with the conversation that we had with a friend of ours that Eric
Simmons? Yeah. And he told us about this moment. Yeah, that was kind of strange.
This is the, the San Jose sharks actually. Who is this a?
This is a hockey team or a yeah, hockey team. And like I,
I'm pretty strongly identified with, with hockey to begin with.
Like I play hockey. My Dad has played hockey his entire life. Um,
and the sharks started in the bay area like when I was 10 years old.
The sharks are my favorite, favorite creature by a long ways.
And so I've rooted for them forever. And for like the last like six years,
they've been really good.
Every year they're picked at the beginning of the year to go to the Stanley Cup,
maybe to win the Stanley Cup. And every year they fall short.
And so in 2007 they were in the playoffs. The sharks are the top seed.
They're playing the eight seed, which also is Anaheim,
which is probably their biggest arrival and they lose.
Oh, and I remember driving home from the ice rink,
it was probably about midnight and it was a really pretty night out,
like the city lights and they're like shimmering on the water and there's always
these tankers out like parked in the bay.
There's like the silhouettes of the boats and the Oakland coastline and the San
Francisco shoreline and like this is everything that makes me happy in the
world. Eric says usually when he sees that view, no matter how he's feeling,
he's like, okay, everything's going to be good.
It's going to be fine because that is one putable city.
But that night I was so
angry that I remember noticing this like this like beautiful scene and thinking,
I hate this. I hate everything about it. Burn down in flames
like I, that's embarrassing.
The fact that these guys that I don't know lost a hockey game in Dallas that has
the power to override everything I think I like about myself and just turn me
into this like drooling, savage, angry beast. I don't like that.
Yeah. What I love about that story, by the way,
you know Eric is so taken with the subject that he's writing a book about it at
the moment. Anyway, go ahead.
But what I love about that story is it's so typical, you know,
almost every sports fan has had a moment where you're like,
I cannot believe my own emotions right now. Are you a burner? I mean, do you,
I'm not know. I mean, I watch sports, but I don't get into that.
I don't get into a darkness. I do.
There have definitely been times I've wanted to burn down New York and if you
ever asked yourself like, yeah,
well that's the question, right? Yeah. For this hour anyway,
like why is it that something as trivial as a hockey game feel like life or
death, which probably doesn't happen to a lot of public radio people, but hey,
we'll input because you shouldn't think that. Yeah. All right. All right.
[inaudible] you widened the category a little bit and just said Games Belden.
You'd include everybody right? Game everybody.
So then what is it about a game that makes it more than a game?
Yeah, well let's find out.
Radiolab. I'm Robert Krulwich. I'm Chad Abu Mirage. They with us
sports to me as a kid were vital. Sports were the,
like if everything else on the planet had disappeared except for sports,
I would've been fine if, if, if the church had gone away of school,
had gone away, even if all my brothers and sisters had gone away,
I liked them fine.
But sports was the only thing that I really loved as a kid.
Can you introduce yourself?
My name is Stephen Dubner and Stephen a is the author of freaking off
Freakonomics, the books, the blog, and I've got my own ISD in line,
kind of an inside joke.
And it's a fancy piece of studio equipment because now freakonomics is also a
radio show we talking to you like in your living room.
And the reason we call Steven up, and this is the honest truth,
is that Soren Wheeler,
one of our producers overheard Steven telling this story in the men's room.
That's where I do most of my research for the show, actually answering the door.
I look for friends
in case sworn overheard Steven and the stall got him to come into the studio and
tell to us, cause this is a story about a boy, a hero, and a dad,
and how those three things can get a little intertwined.
I don't really know what happened.
What I know is that when I came into being in 1963 I was the last of eight kids
and Steven says already at that point sports was family law. In fact,
when it came to baseball, no two people in the family,
including my mother and father's, there were 10 of us.
No two people rooted for the same team. And as it turned out,
there was even a rule. No two people were allowed to root for the same team.
Now he says his dad actually assigned each of the family members their own
baseball team and told them,
this is your team only you get to root for this team.
So my dad was a mets fan. My mom, I don't remember,
but I had a sister who was a red sox fan,
was a cardinals fan by San Francisco giants fans and La Dodgers Fan.
That was my brother Peter.
And I have no recollection of a time before I was a Baltimore Orioles Fan.
So I think what happened is Stevie was born. Here's another kid,
we need another team. Who Does he get? How about the Orioles?
When I was just like the tooth fairy sticking a dollar under your pillow,
how did he assign the oils to you? Okay, so first of all,
I should just say like a lot of things in life as a very young,
very obedient Catholic boy, I accepted this mystery without question.
But here's my hunch. My father,
I think felt that it was a shame that he couldn't give more to his materially
more and even more of himself and so in my mind,
the greatest gift he could give to each of us was our own baseball team.
No,
but this is ultimately a story about more than just baseball.
Okay.
My parents were both Brooklyn born Jews, kind of typical.
I'm second generation American who before they met each other,
while they were in their twenties they both converted to Roman Catholicism.
What was the reaction from their parents? Oh, that was bad. That was bad.
The way that my grandfather discovered that my father had had converted was when
some rosary beads slipped out of his pocket and fell onto the floor.
So it was like my grandfather basically threw my father out of the house,
literally declared him dead. Wow.
Set Shit before him until he says when his dad met,
his mom was another Jewish convert to Catholicism.
They were like two refugees who'd found each other exactly together.
They left Brooklyn, went upstate,
spent all their money on an old farmhouse in the country,
leaving behind a past that was toxic.
But then when they got upstate, they found themselves a little out of place.
We were these kinds of farmers, Jewish, Brooklyn,
Jewish city people who are now upstate Catholic farmers,
survivor types. We had no money, a lot of kids. And my dad,
he said his dad would often be upstairs, quote, lying down for hours and hours,
which didn't make a whole lot of sense to him at the time.
He thought they'll come on, why isn't he down here with us? But now as an adult,
he understands that his dad was not well. In fact, he was depressed. Yeah.
Really depressed.
And how much did you know about your parent's backstory when you were growing up
and on the farm? Uh, can my knowledge be measured in negative terms,
but it was plain to me that my father was a kind of diminished man,
that he wasn't capable of doing all the things that other men were capable of
doing.
So Stevens says he would go outside to the backyard and he'd spend time by
himself pretending to be the Oreo recreating the games that had been played the
day before in your life.
And here come Pike Robbin, he still spearheading the Oriole,
you know, one game could last me six, eight hours and I would literally,
I would literally play 162 game seasons,
make the two guns.
I would be every batter on both teams and the announcers
Robinson completes his home run trial.
And you know this thing about ownership and whether my dad did that on purpose
or not, he did make me feel like if, if they fail then they needed me to,
to boost them up. And that kept him busy for awhile.
But then the play happens and everything changes
to explain. Somewhere along the way, when he was 10 Stephen discovers football,
football
[inaudible]
was considered barbaric. Worst of all,
it was played on the Saturday. The regardless, he fell in love with it.
I love it.
Route 47
the fact that all these guys wear helmets that made them look kind of like kind
of like knights and almost immediately he latched onto a particular running back
from the Pittsburgh steel and that was Franco Harris
[inaudible].
I discovered Franco Harris and his rookie season read about him in sports
illustrated and from the beginning everything about him just made sense.
I came from a big Catholic family. He came from a big Catholic family.
His family was kind of mixed, so his Franco's, his dad was black,
the mom was Italian. He was very unusual guy,
very kind of thoughtful and quiet and I became a big Steelers fan because of
him, which brings us back to the
proud of Spanish.
Saturday,
December 23rd all those Christmas 1972 MS Steelers were about to lose to them.
The Oakland writers have taken a lead.
40 seconds left on the clock. We had the ball on something like our own 35
forth down at 10 yards to go last gas. Hang onto your hats.
Here come the Steelers out of the huddle. Very Brad shot to control.
Brad tried drops back to pass back running out of the pocket looking for
somebody that pro two fires it down,
field Bradshaw throws and justice or see what's about to catch it and gets
crushed.
The ball pops up, goes falling through the air
and right before the ball hits the ground, Franco Harris,
his guy zooms into the frame out of nowhere and catches it in full stride at his
shoe tops.
[inaudible] Franco runs 60 yards into the end zone time runs out, Steelers win.
Shortly thereafter,
this play was dubbed the immaculate reception.
[inaudible] Christmas Burkle. There was a miracle of all vertical
for me as a kid watching it where my team won and my guy was like,
I was
sealed for life. In fact,
this guy was so much his guy that when Steve would write his homework papers,
he began signing the papers. Franco Dubner. Wow.
And I thought of myself as Franco Dubner, which I mean,
I know it sounds funny now, but it's very naturally.
We're all named for saints to start with. I mean,
my oldest brother was named Joseph. My oldest sister was named Mary.
So we're your name for saints.
Wally Franco was my sane the following thanksgiving.
Stephen's parents drove off to a prayer meeting,
was part of this religious offshoot that they participated in called the
charismatic Christian Renewal. Very fervent group, lots of speaking in tongues.
It was strange and a little scary to me to see my parents speaking in tongues.
Steven would sometimes go, but this time he did.
So his parents drove off to the meeting in Albany kind of far from our house and
a few hours later only his mother returned.
My mother comes home and tells us dad had an attack.
She told him in the middle of the meeting, he just fell over.
He was in the hospital now,
but it would be out of the hospital in time for Christmas.
So that's all I heard. I was a 10 year old kids like,
oh my dad's coming home for Christmas. Cool. Right.
And the football playoffs are coming up month later.
It was the 21st of December almost exactly a year after the immaculate
reception. It was the last day of school before Christmas break was a half day.
We had grab bag, Christmas gift exchange at school,
Stephen Races home from school, pretty excited.
Playoffs are coming up and my dad's coming home and then my mother comes in and
says, uh, dad died,
uh,
I'm going to go upstairs to lie down.
[inaudible]
that is when the dream began. No,
he's not exactly sure if it was that night or maybe the next,
but when he went to bed and closed his eyes,
this is what would happen. I would go to the VFW hall in Albany.
This is a place his dad had taken him were Franco Harris was giving a talk and I
would invite him to come back to my house,
way out in the boondocks for Spaghetti and meatballs. And in my dream,
he would come back, he would eat the spaghetti. It wasn't terrible.
Then I would say, hey, you want to go out in the,
in the yard and play some football? And we would go out and it's dark. Yeah.
And it's just me and him where this skill or it against some other mythical
teams, darkness. Yet we're playing on our field in our backyard.
And I'm kind of embarrassed because our backyard is all lumpy with frozen a cow
hoof principal. Cause sometimes we'd stick the cow back there
and on the second to the last play of the game,
it's like we're behind by three points.
Franco would turn his ankle and one of these cow hoof prints and then we'd hand
the ball. Yeah,
to me. And he'd say, kid, you have to take it from here yourself.
What was the look on his face? We need hand you the ball and give you kids.
You know Jesus on the cross space.
Jesus on the cross because he's in pain, he's got a beard.
He's kind of sweating and dripping and frying a little bit.
And then I'd have to run it in for the winning touch and the dream.
But the dream would always fade there. I'd never knew if I made it or not.
And he says the next night he had the same dream.
Exactly who the same in the next night,
the same in the next day. Same in the next night.
Same almost every night for about three or four years in the next night.
The same. So I, you know, I had that dream several hundred,
maybe a thousand times. Yep. And every time you woke up from that dream,
I'm just curious, how did you feel?
What I remember feeling is that Franco Harris came to see me and that he
couldn't win the game for me,
but that he was on my side and he wanted me to win kind of period.
Um,
so if we were to stop this story right now,
this would be a story like many others.
You've heard boy falls in love with athlete, dreams of athlete goes out,
leaves athlete behind. But this is a different one.
Eventually after a few years, Steven stopped having the dream.
He moved out of the house, went off to school, got married, became an adult,
pretty much forgot about Franco. But then
something happened purely by accident. Living in New York, maybe, I don't know,
15, 18 years ago,
I caught sight of him on the cover of black enterprise magazine.
Franco had become a very successful small businessman.
And my heart just started to thump like it had when I was a kid.
And I thought I gotta, I gotta get to know Franco. So he, uh,
tracked down frank as address, wrote him letters and then more letters.
And to make a long story short, one day the phone rang and it was him.
He did agree to meet with me.
I told him I'd like to write a book about a boy getting to know his childhood
here on trying to figure out what that person is like in reality.
And I was also interested in, I, um,
I was very careful in my mind that first day that I met him in Pittsburgh.
Say, don't tell him the dream,
don't tell the dream because he will think that you were a fricking lunatic.
Right. That first day I told him the dream. I couldn't,
it's like this, his reaction was he clarified,
he doesn't show her. He's a very interesting fellow. He's got a really, uh,
he's got a really interesting manner, a very low key.
They did end up meeting a few times. Uh, Steven wrote his book,
but he says Franco was always really careful to keep them at arms length.
I would say at anytime they kind of got close,
Franco would sort of disappear a little bit. In fact,
toward the end of the book project, they make an appointment to meet.
I get to Pittsburgh a couple of days early.
Typical and frank is not there. Actually,
Steven ends up standing in a parking lot waiting for him and waiting and waiting
and waiting. And then eventually we heads back to New York.
And I guess I thought that somehow he had a lot to teach me, you know,
about being a man, being in a real, a real grownup,
um, being a father. Um, and he was polite and uh,
and just not really that interested.
And it was around this point that Steven decided, you know,
maybe that's what he was trying to tell me in the dream and in real life too,
that no one can save you but yourself.
Part of his Messiah job was to persuade me that, you know,
everybody's got to be their own messiah. That was the message.
But isn't that disappointing to you? This guy was your, your hero.
You want him to be all these things. And he didn't want to be those things back.
I mean, that must have hurt a little, you know, look, um,
Frankel Harris didn't fall in love with, you know, me.
He didn't want to be my best friend, but that, that aside,
he is an exemplary human being. He's a really, he's a good human being.
I think you can easily go too far.
I think you can put too much of your emotional life in the hands of people who
have, you know, who don't know you and, and have no responsibility for you.
But I think sports fandom is a fantastic gift with almost immeasurable value,
um, and my weight. But why? I mean, really, I mean, I love sports, but I mean,
he's just a running back. He's not saying what exactly about sports. It makes,
it gives it in the measurable value. Yeah.
Um, it's a proxy for real life, but better. Uh, you know, it renews itself.
It's constantly happening in real time.
There are conflicts that seem to carry real consequences,
but at the end of the day, don't, that's war where nobody dies.
It's a proxy for all our emotions and desires and hopes. I mean, heck,
what's not to like about sports? There you go.
You just Sorta, you just wrap it all up in a little bell right there. That was
awesome.
[inaudible] Stephen Dubner
is the author of confessions of a hero worshiper,
and he is the host of the public radio show, freakonomics.
Check them out at Freakonomics, radio.com we will move on to other heroes,
other sports and other puzzles in just a moment.